thank you everyone for coming sorry for
the hiccup so today we're gonna talk
about using neural networks for time
series prediction so to give an outline
of this talk just in general this talk
is actually going through a particular
problem that I wanted to solve and how I
use neural networks to solve this
problem don't see this content as the
canonical source of truth for how to use
neural networks to solve a problem this
is just how I use neural networks to
solve problem so to begin we're gonna
introduce the problem that we wanted to
solve you want to remember what you're
actually trying to do not just how we're
doing it then we're gonna talk about
phrasing this kind of business problem
or not the business problem as a machine
learning problem then we're gonna
collect and apply data to solve our
problem we're gonna go over how we
selected features from our data to
answer the questions we want to answer
then how we can creat Li train the model
finally some improvements we made to the
model and some general tips and problems
that I encountered along the way to give
you some context I work at a company
called quant opium we build tools for
people to do quantitative finance we
have things like hosted jupiter'
notebooks and a simulator for running
strategies over historical data I'm
mostly focused on working with time
series data and integrating new time
series data in the platform so I've seen
all kinds of things like market data
sentiment data earnings estimates you
know satellite image data you name it
I've looked at a lot of really
interesting time series data but today
we're going to talk about my personal
favorite time series so we're gonna talk
about a video game called oath oath is a
rhythm game where you click circles to
the rhythm of music the game is pretty
simple you have circles where you click
with your mouse you have sliders where
you click and drag along the path of the
slider and then you have your mouse
cursor itself the way the game works is
you score three hundred points for
clicking a circle exactly on the beat
you score 100 points if you're slightly
off the beat and the game will display a
little notification that you are off the
beat you score 50 points if you're
really off the beat like by more than a
sixteenth note
and you will see another indication
telling you that finally if you don't
click the circle or you click with
almost no regard for rhythm then you're
gonna get a miss well in the game shows
a little X so I could try to explain how
it works but I'm just gonna show you a
little video of the game itself and
there's no sound imagine there's your
favorite anime music playing to this
because it's all Japanese songs so this
is an example of the game on a slower
difficulty or an easier difficulty and
the next clip is the game on a
difficulty that I would normally play it
yeah so the game speeds up a lot
okay so to freeze the actual problem
what I wanted to do was improve my rank
very quickly so the game gives you
points depending on how well you do on
songs and how hard they are there are
many new songs that are being made every
week it's an open-source game and
there's a large community of people who
actually create the songs and the layout
of the circles importantly though the
songs were very difficulties and
different players have different play
styles so I have a particular play style
and I find some songs harder or easier
than other songs even if the game
objectively ranks them a certain way so
this presents an arbitrage opportunity
where I can try to find songs that I
will do better on then that are even
that are ranked harder so to phrase this
as a machine learning problem what I
want to do is predict my score on a
given beat map so to do that we need to
compute the accuracy percentage and
which breaks down to the temporal
accuracy so how on rhythm so I am and
whether I will click the circles or not
so to give an overview of machine
learning models in general machine
learning models mostly fall into two
categories we have classifiers which
take a sample and label it as a member
of one of a finite set of classes so
this is useful for things like image
classification we're given an image you
want to know is this is this a picture
of a dog or a cat or the number one and
you know what all of your classes are
ahead of time
you also have regressors which
approximate an arbitrary numeric
function which are much more general so
at this point sorry and then since this
is about time series data we have LST M
models which is a type of time series
neural network which allows you to model
order dependent data these mostly model
an idea of a sequence of observations
and the way that these use the time
aspect is you train on instead of a
single sample you give it a window of
time sorted observations so the phrase
our problem as one of either a
classifier or
neural network are a regresar sorry we
could try using a classifier where we
would label every circle in a song so
for every single hit object which is a
time series itself we would label it is
a 300 a 100 250 or miss the other option
would be to use a regresar where we
would predict some type of error metric
here I've talked about a mirror which is
the XY error so where you are clicking
on the screen and the accuracy error
which is your punctuality or the
temporal error in the song at this point
I didn't actually know which to use so I
decided I would go look at the empirical
data that I have collected so the first
thing piece of data we have is a beat
map so this is where all the circles are
paired with the song itself so we have
all our hit objects the circles and
sliders and they're in X Y x space so
you can think of this as a big 3d
alright we also have some scalar values
associated with every song we have the
circle size which is how big how many
pixels a circle is on the screen we have
the approach rate which is the time
between a circle appearing on the screen
and you needing to click it to achieve
the correct score and there's also the
overall difficulty which is the width of
the thresholds so this is how many
milliseconds away from the beat can you
be before you score a 100 or 50 and
those are different in different songs
looking at our raw data we see this just
kind of a text file with a bunch of
coordinates and information and and it's
not super structured it's not just like
you know PD that reads CSV or something
there's also modifiers so you can play
the if you find that a song is too easy
you can make it harder by making all the
circles smaller or flipping the map
using hard rock there's also double time
which doubles the speed of the song it
is used in the second example as well as
hidden which makes the circles disappear
before you have to click them so they
appear on the screen then they disappear
then you click them that was also used
in the second example and there are a
couple others that change the way the
game is played we also have replay data
so the reason that I
actually do this was that the game
records replay every time you play which
is a time series of your cursor location
as well as the keyboard state so it's
just a bit mask of what keys are being
pressed you don't actually click with
your mouse
normally you click with the keyboard you
press a key on the keyboard also I have
about seven years of replays so I have a
large enough data set that I can
actually do some machine learning here
so to understand a little bit more about
our data I mentioned that one of the
metrics was the overall difficulty this
is a table showing how many milliseconds
it takes to score a 300 so you'll notice
on the hardest difficulty you have 19
and 1/2 milliseconds to score 300 the
problem that this presents is that any
given 300 is not directly comparable to
another 300 or 100 is not directly
comparable to any other 100 so if I
wanted to use a classifier on this model
just labeling something as a 300 isn't
exactly enough because on an easy song
you should get more 300 even for the
same error also in looking through my
replay data this is a the distributions
of the scores so I'm pretty good at the
game so I mostly just score 300 and not
100's or 50s so the classes are
extremely biased so if I wanted to train
a classifier on this it doesn't actually
see a lot of examples of 100's or 50s or
misses so I went ahead and tried to use
a regresar so I needed to actually get
the metrics that I was talking about so
to join the data I find all the clicks
by taking the times when the keyboard
state changes and then I match the click
temporally with the the nearest hit
object an important thing is this
ignores a feature of the game called hit
locking so I'm pour'd to know what that
is it's just that this is a
simplification of the way the game is
played this is not actually how you
would resolve whether you clicked a
circle or not but it's it's good enough
and and we can make these kinds of
simplifications for the sake of modeling
the game so to get the accuracy error I
just took the absolute difference in
time and the nice thing about this is
that it eliminates the overall
difficulty metric from the game I'm just
going to predict the
in the clique and I don't know yet what
that score would be and that's okay so
we don't need to model that feature for
the aim error I just take the distance
between where I click and the center of
the circle again this is nice because I
can compare the error across different
circle sizes I don't know whether I hit
or not just what the error is
now we have to extract some features so
what is a future a feature is the
numeric inputs that you feed into your
model so I said that regressor is
approximating a numeric function it
can't just take whatever I actually have
to give it some numbers so for LST M
models this is really what we are
observing so I said it's a sequence of
observations what is in observation
those are your features this allows us
also to focus our model on important
aspects of our data and this is where we
get to use our domain knowledge so to
revisit this is what a beat mat looks
like it has some structure it actually
has a lot of structure but it's not
immediately obvious so one option would
be to try to just feed a neural network
like a big text blob and try to learn
something from it I think in theory that
should work but we know a lot more
information about what is in this text
we know so looking at the first row this
says that we have a circle at actually
we have a slider at 103 270 250 2000
milliseconds into the song it's a linear
slider that goes from that first
coordinate to 111 by 176 so there's a
lot of important structure here and it
would take a long time to learn it so
instead we can just extract that and
instead of feeding it the text blob
we're gonna feed it in a ray of numbers
so some simple features that we can
extract from these beatmap files are the
absolute X Y and time for every hit
object I also said that this was a
chance to use some domain knowledge so
one domain specific feature that I've
used is the angle through a circle that
you click so here if we have three
circles in order of one two and three I
would label circle two with this
here and I believe that this has some
effect on whether I can click this
circle because it is literally how fast
I have to change the direction with my
cursor one interesting thing though is
that I can't exactly explain how the
angle affects my ability to click the
circle but I believe it has some effect
and more importantly I actually believe
it has an effect on my ability to click
the next circle so I think the angle of
two more more directly affects my score
on circle three than on circle two but
because we are using a time series model
the lsdm model the sequence of
observations will be learned so we can
actually have the order of those angles
get some information for us
so I also said that we've been we're not
just going to train on a sequence of
observation but little time windows so
here's a table of some circles from a
song with their time and x and
y-coordinates so to construct these
windows what we're going to do is select
one row of observations and then draw
some context around that so here I'm
saying that we are going to look at the
leading four circles and then the
following two circles in most models if
you ever wanted to do real-time
predictions you would not be able to
look at the following data because you
don't have it yet but here I already
have all my data ahead of time so I can
look at the circles that come after it
also in the game you can see the circles
before you're supposed to click them so
I believe that the circles that follow
the one I'm trying to click are much
more important in determining whether I
will click the one I'm trying to click
now that makes some sense
so once we've drawn this window we can
actually generate some new features
where we take relative offsets from
these observations and we're going to
take the difference in the x coordinate
and the difference in the y coordinate
from the center of our window and all of
the other observations what this is do
it's it's telling the model that not
only is the absolute position on the
screen important but it is the distance
between all of the objects that's
important and then you just slide this
window through the entire song and
generate a bunch of little windows
you might be thinking can all this
information be learned just from the
absolute positions because the model
could theoretically learn the
differences or what it's important and
that's true but this goes back to
focusing the model so it takes a really
long time to train this already I want
to make it a little faster and I'm
saying these differences are important
you should focus on those this is just a
list of all the features I have one
thing to notice you don't need to make
relative versions of all of your
features I don't know how I don't
actually care about the relative angles
I just care about the absolute angles
through all the circles for example
alright so talk about the inputs now we
actually need to train this thing so we
need to generate a big numeric array of
all of the data we want a feed to our
model so the feature arrays or the input
store model is going to be a 3d array
the first thing we have is the number of
features so this would be all of that
big list before so this is for each
single scalar observation by the window
length so then we have our windows of
observations finally by the number of
windows that we have so this is a
sequence of little time windows through
our songs and then we have to label our
data so we're going to have two parallel
arrays which are just 1d arrays which is
the length of the number of windows and
these are going to be our two error
metrics and you might be thinking
couldn't this just be a number of
windows by two array but there's
actually a good reason to split them
which I'll cover in a second so we're
gonna use Kerris for our actual training
Harris is an amazing library it's built
on top of tensorflow for doing neural
network stuff
so to start you create an input node in
your computation graph and what this
says is that the shape of our input
our window length by Len features or
number of features you might note that
this does not have the number of
observations so this is saying what is
the shape of a single observation next
we're going to just use Karis --is LS TN
implementation this is the magic part
you don't need to write this or learn
how the LS TM works you can just use it
and it's implemented very well so to do
that we just say how big how many
neurons we want in our LS TM node and we
feed it the input the way you figure out
how many neurons you want is through
trial and error and asking your your
friends and co-workers I I don't know
the answer to that next we're gonna
define the outputs of our model we're
gonna start with our aim air and this is
going to be a Karass dense node with one
value that's what the 1 there is and you
pick some activation function you also
do that by asking your friends and
coworkers
and here we can name it so we're gonna
call this this node the aim error and we
feed that the previous node in the graph
which is the lsdm and then we're going
to do the same thing for our accuracy
are so again you might think Clint I
just predict a - like a tuple instead of
two scalar values but one nice feature
if Kerris is that if you split them up
like this
you can name them separately and then
when you're training you get to see the
loss or the how poorly the model is
predicting these things for each
different value so you get to just name
them and it makes everything look a
little nicer yeah and then need to just
throw this graph into a model object or
we specify our inputs as the input
object and our two outputs as the two
error metrics then you compile it and
picking those parameters is the same as
before to actually fit the model you
feed it your features array which was
that number of windows by window length
by number of features array and then we
pass a dictionary with our two parallel
arrays of our error metrics so I want to
train this model and then to predict
sorry you give it a
an array the same shape as your input
and it will spit out the two scalar
values that we've named so I wouldn't
train this I want to evaluate it and it
just looked terrible so at first it just
was predicting basically random noise
and I didn't understand why so I talked
to some people and they told me that
neural networks are extremely sensitive
to the input ranges so you can't just be
giving it arbitrary numeric values you
need to Center them and they need to
have a standard deviation of one so to
do that you take your or your feature
array and you subtract out the mean and
you divide through by the standard
deviation you want to do this column
wise so this is for every single feature
you do this a very important thing you
need to save the mean and standard
deviation of the training data because
when you take your the data you want to
predict with you need to subtract out
the mean of your training data and
divide through by the standard deviation
of your training data not of the data
you're predicting with so I went and
scaled it and it was still terrible it
was just predicting random noise
so I looked at the raw data that I had
and so these are the some features the
absolute x and absolute y mean looks
good for both of them but it appeared
that I had some outliers so a thing to
know is that the OHS playfield the
actual screen size is 512 by 384 so
those those maxes didn't seem right
so I actually dive into this one so this
is a picture from the game editor which
is the tool used to make the maps this
is a slider zooming in on this slider
you'll see there's a bunch of little
points there this is supposed to be a
piecewise linear function that connects
all those points but this map is ten
years old and they've changed the data
format so I accidentally was
interpreting this as a Bezier curve with
all of those as control points so using
matplotlib I can plot the expected path
which looks like the thing we saw in the
game but I was interpreting that as a
really high order Bezier curve which
looks like this and if we zoom out to
show how long that tail is a
it's pretty big so the interesting thing
about this was that it was a not just a
problem it was not actually not a
problem house he's in Karras and all
that seemed to be correct and I spent a
lot of time thinking I was using
kerosene correctly but really it was a
problem in my data collection pipeline
it was like this was a problem because I
had a ten-year-old file and my open
source parser for this didn't work not
that I was like using ml wrong but if
your data is garbage
your ml stuff doesn't work so kind of
circling back to the original problem
I wanted to predict my accuracy and I've
just got these two arrow metrics now so
we need to discretize our scores but
these score thresholds are pretty big
windows and if my model says I think
you're gonna you're gonna click with
19.4 milliseconds of error and I the
song is OD 10 well if I just said okay
I'm gonna score that as 300 that's not
actually capturing that I was right on
that fat boundary and the difference
between the 300 and 100 dramatically
affects the accuracy that you'll achieve
so I wanted something that would capture
the boundary like how close you were to
the boundaries so I looked at the data
that I had and this is the distribution
of the aim errors in all of my replays
for the last like two years other than
an outlier up by like 70 it looks like a
pretty good log normal distribution then
the temporal accuracy I did the same
thing there are these spikes and there
they're not actually bidding errors this
is because there's more errors that are
multiples of the milliseconds of the
PPM's of the songs that I play so
there's actually some regularity to that
error but I said it was close enough to
a log normal so what I decided to do was
take my predictions and actually fit a
log normal distribution to them and then
take the expected value of all of my
predictions instead of taking the
scalars so just I think this codes kind
of cool so I wanted to go through it so
the way this works is can people read
this in the back well
almost I don't know how to make it
bigger really quickly sorry so what I do
is I predict the differences so the
first line is using Karis to actually
predict the two parallel arrays which
are the two error metrics for every
circle we then fit each of those so for
all the circles we fit them to a
distribution for the whole song to take
whether I'm going to click or not it is
the cumulative distribution function at
the radius of the circles so it's the
area under the error distribution before
the circle radius and then to compute
the expected value for the temporal
accuracy this is an ASCII art picture of
a probability density function which I
put in my code because I have a visual
intuition for how this works and I know
I'm gonna forget this if I don't have
this picture you can just take the
weighted sum of the the areas and that
gives you the expected value of the
temporal accuracy and then you just
multiply them together and now you have
the expected score on a song so I was
running this for a while and it was
making predictions that assumed I was
really good at the game so I liked the
structure the errors that it was
predicting were things that I thought
would be harder there was interesting
structure in how the errors were but the
magnitudes were too low so looking again
at this the distribution of the errors
that I have empirically they're mostly
really small so maybe it's hard to have
an intuition for how big the circles are
but 19.4 5 milliseconds was the
threshold for 300 on the hardest
difficulty so in from the histogram we
noticed there was a lot of three
hundreds so I was much more interested
in the outlier conditions or the the
notes that were going to be predicted to
be hard than notes that were predicted
to be easy so I wanted to tell my model
to focus more attention on the difficult
notes than on the easy notes and to do
that we can use Karis to weigh each
sample for each different error
so what I did was I said that anything
that was one standard deviation above
the mean or below would be weighed at
1/4 and then anything that was four
standard deviations or above would be
weighed at one and then just a linear
scale between them so what this does is
it says that all of my outlier
conditions are more important than all
of the regular data that I saw and this
actually made the model make slightly
better predictions now to look at some
out-of-sample data what I did was I
downloaded a new song I never played
before
played it a couple times and then asked
what my my prediction would be so for
the first play this is what the plot
looks like second play you'll notice I
scored a 50 at the end there on a note
and then the third play through then
this is what the predictions are so
you'll notice that the charts aren't
exactly the same but one problem well
one thing to know is that I fynd the
same songs many times into my model with
very different scores because I play
songs more than once which is why did
the expected value thing but it does
identify that second high peak at the at
the back right there is the same note
that I scored a 50 on and I scored a 100
on it and almost all of my plays so that
it is actually picking out some
interesting features of the songs but
the real thing I wanted this for was to
arbitrage the game's score mechanism so
the the far right column here is the
game score the left column is my
prediction and then the right is my
actual so the first three are the the
three songs plays that I showed the
charts of so my actual and the
prediction is really close again the
percentages have pretty large jumps
because the scores are discretized from
300 100 or 50 but then the second two or
the last two are interesting the song is
harder and it predicts a lower score
than the first song and I do score lower
but the final row has is even harder
than the previous one and the game my
model predicts I will do better on it
and then empirically I do so I am
finding some
difference in how I play from the way
the game scores so that I count that as
a success some general tips which I'll
go through quickly because I think I
only have five minutes three minutes
used for both flags to log information
as you're going but make it optional
because if you actually want to deploy
this you probably don't want to print
after every single line but training
some of these models and cleaning your
data can take a long time so you want to
have some insight into where you are in
the pipeline for progress indicators
like scikit-learn or Kara's have when
you're training you can use click dot
progress bar to build your own and print
summary statistics as early as possible
in your processes I would have saved a
lot of time if I just printed the
outliers of my data instead of training
multiple times on basically garbage
software engineering still matters so
one thing I found really helpful is to
group all my models into domain-specific
objects which handle things like feature
extraction scaling label extraction and
managing the Charis model this lets me
change the implementation of my model
later and not have to like fix
everything else it's not just a hundred
function scattered around I just call
fit and predict and it takes domain
objects and returns domain values and
this also facilitates serialization so a
really interesting thing you can do with
your models is save them so this allows
you to do things like training on ec2
and then sending the results back to you
to use locally or going the other way
where you train on one machine and then
send the pre-fit model to another
machine to actually deploy this is a
feature that's supported by Karis so all
you need to do is wrap up all of your
domain-specific stuff and then you can
delegate serialization to Karis so that
you can save everything together some
key points of you if you only remember
stuff remember these most of the work is
going to be done before you get to Karis
I thought for a long time like I hadn't
actually done ml even when I had a
website running where people could
upload data and I would train models for
them like it's actually all the data
cleaning before Charis Charis is so good
that you won't spend a lot of time using
it and that's a testament to how good
care
is not that you are not doing machine
learning and then more importantly
understand your data and the data
collection process it's not just what
data you have but how did you get that
data because you might find like biases
in the data like all of my clicks are
three hundreds and that's just how the
data is being collected that's not a
problem with the data itself and finally
os-- is a really fun game you should
play it thank you so all of all the code
I showed so the model itself how I
implemented it is on github under my
github which is ten lowercase LS / Lane
the tools for actually parsing all of
the data and creating the arrays and
stuff is slider and then combine is a
service that runs a website in an IRC
BOTS where you can train your own model
and you can message my account in the
game to get predictions in Jody are us
on Twitter or social media I'm on
Twitter dunder qual name yes
alright we have a couple of minutes for
questions does anybody have a question
in the audience that you wouldn't like
Jody well then why neural networks why
not random forests or any other machine
learning model as you said a lot of the
a lot of the value you're providing is
in the future engineering so there's my
learning exercise but do you have any
thoughts on to why this particular
problem would be better suited or worse
suited for needle networks so I actually
tried using a different kind of model is
using I try actually like a bunch of
different things and scikit-learn like a
large suite of things but I wanted
something that took the template the
temporal aspect of the circles into
account I'm sure there's probably a way
to do that with other models but this
was just the one I tried
um hi just out of curiosity using LT SM
did you try this with a soft max layer
and were you able to see kind of which
which predictions were more or less
accurate just to get a feel for how they
felt like you with that with that um
that that extra layer at the bottom no I
did not but I would love to talk to you
afterwards about that I'm not really a
machine learning experts I kind of just
tried most of the carrot stuff out of
the box so if people have tips for more
advanced machine learning stuff I'm sure
a lot of people want to ask and I'm not
sure if you mentioned that how long
actually that took you from kind of
starting with the model to actually
perfectly because I think that's that's
what everybody is on everybody's mind
what that sort of period of time yeah
so the project in total probably took
like five months maybe more maybe like
six or seven a large part of that was
writing the lower level tools to like
parse the files and parse the replays
and compute scores and things like that
the model itself probably took like two
months of work but this was all like on
free time so most of that was like
researching stuff and talking to people
and trying to find when people are
available so so how much and I think you
mentioned about how much you know sort
of emphasis you would take that actually
being able to communicate and ask
questions you know with the right people
yeah one of the most important things
for this was being able to talk to like
my roommates and co-workers and people
who knew various parts of it or
different things and like that's a great
resource for people thank you any more
questions
Oh in the back I this be our last
question sorry
yeah I think for the talk I was just
wondering with neural networks for time
series there's this question of
stationarity right I mean I imagine your
skill changed probably plateaued at some
point right so was some high percentage
degree well maybe you're still growing
but most of it you probably was like
sigmoid or something so why'd you cut
out there really early data with this to
improve your picture that's kind of
thing yeah that's actually a great point
so I actually throw away everything but
the last like six months of data because
I am not put on I'm getting better every
day
so yeah so if when I trained with all of
the data it would be like the same song
but I'm scoring like terribly on it and
then now like yesterday I play it a
perfect score so the model was not
really learning anything interesting
because it didn't know like how that was
affected one way I think you can still
use some of that data is you can use the
weighing again so you can weigh samples
that are older as less important and way
newer samples more I didn't look into
that I just throw away everything but
the last six months because I play this
game a lot so that was still enough data
thank you everybody
[Applause]